Sam Brinton do you remember him Sam
Brenton is the former nuclear waste
appointee in the Biden Administration
he's the guy who's a bald-headed
Mustachio dude who frequently dresses up
as a woman who flaunts his leather puppy
fetish he likes to dress men up as dogs
and all sorts of leather and then do
weird sexual things to them and he likes
to wear lipstick and flowing dresses and
high heels and he was feted by the media
they absolutely loved this guy how
groundbreaking he's a transgender pan
gender whatever gender uh cracking the
glass ceiling and he looks so stunning
he's so brave look at his beautiful
clothing then it turned out
that this guy Sam Brinton is a thief
he got caught stealing luggage at an
airport and initially he said oh I was
this was just a mistake I took the wrong
bag and it turned out he's taken other
bags before then they had camera footage
of him actually looking at the name tags
on the bags and hiding them in his
pocket just going away into and it was
really really weird finally after weeks
and weeks of this it was too much even
for the Biden Administration and so they
canned the guy now we find out
that some of those flowing dresses this
big beautiful
wardrobe pieces that Sam Brinton was
photographed in even including in Vanity
Fair by the way in fashion magazines in
high culture
it it turns out that they were stolen
from specific women there's a woman who
posted on Instagram she said hi I'm a
fashion designer this is a this is a
custom piece that I had made and uh
here's Sam Brinton wearing that piece
and I lost my luggage in 2018 and I'm
not saying for sure it was him but it's
hard to explain how he ended up wearing
my dress if he didn't steal my luggage
so this appears to have been going on
for years
uh he there were other people who came
forward said you know here's me wearing
this unique sort of custom piece and
then you look later on and uh here's Sam
Brenton wearing it shortly after I lost
it and he's being photographed by the
media doing doing the very same thing
making it into magazines so what is this
about
is this because Sam Brinton couldn't
afford clothing I suppose he probably
couldn't afford the high-end clothing
that he'd like to steal but I think it's
about more than that
people can generally purchase clothing
you can go to any inexpensive shop today
and buy any kind of flamboyant clothing
this was obviously some weird fetish for
this guy he's a guy who is most well
known not for his career not for his
knowledge of nuclear waste not for
any virtue or Excellence that he's
engaged in he's most well known for
indulging weird fetishes and it would
seem that stealing women's clothing at
the airport was part of that and it's
it's just a sad lesson that this guy had
a lot of things going for him I'm not
going to say he had everything going for
him but he had a lot of things going for
him he was in an important role in a
presidential Administration he had
impressive academic degrees I think he
went to MIT
but he just couldn't get over this
problem that he had this
actually many
and those
ended up being his undoing and the thing
you always ask people when they when
they get their comeuppance is was it
worth it
was it worth it the guy who loses his
family because he slept with his
secretary was it worth it you asked the
guys was it worth it they always say no
yes Sam Brenton you lost your job in a
presidential Administration you're now
effectively unemployable certainly at
that height of your profession was it
worth it so that you could wear some
weird red dress that you took from the
airport I assume he would say no
is it worth it to become a laughing
stock internationally so that you can
lead another depraved man around on a
leash in a leather collar was that
really worth it just so that you could
be physically titillated for five
minutes or whatever no but these people
can't escape it this is a real danger
it's it's this joke that Drew tells Drew
Clavin tells about the guy with an
orange for a head the short version of
the joke is guy walks into a bar he's
got an orange for a head the bartender
says okay I gotta ask what's going on he
says all right well you're not gonna
believe it but I was on a beach I find a
little Genie bottle I rubbed the bottle
Genie comes out says I give you three
wishes I said I don't believe that he
says no I didn't try it he says okay
first wish I won a million dollars knock
knock on the door Pat Sajak here's a
check for a million dollars okay uh
second wish I want to sleep with all the
Playboy bunnies of the Year knock knock
it's all the Playboy bunnies of the year
they walk up isn't that unbelievable
bartender says okay I get it
but hat how did you end up with the
orange he said well here's where I think
I messed up for my third wish I asked to
have an orange for a head
and and half the people think this joke
is hilarious and half the people have no
idea what the joke is about the joke is
about the perversity of the human heart
and how these little weird bizarre
shameful perversions can be people's
undoing the rest of the show
continues now
we are going into fake headline Friday
I need your help help me identify the
fake headline among the real headlines
of Mr Davies has given me you don't want
to miss it go to dailywear.com
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign